So I'm recording. Could you just tell me
maybe what you had for breakfast? Yeah,
nothing.
I had nothing for breakfast.
I never eat breakfast just once a day.
All right,
we're going to talk about that for sure.
Let me just pause this optimal
and start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for years.
I love audiobooks and I've two
to recommend right off the bat.
Number one is press my favorite
audio book of all time,
and that is the graveyard
book by Neil Gaiman.
The only audiobook I've wanted to
immediately listen to a second time.
As soon as I finished. It's amazing.
You will thank me. The graveyard book.
The second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
which had a huge impact on my life and
formed the basis for a lot of what became
the four hour workweek.
So all you need to do to get your free
audio book and a Free 30 Day trial is go
to audible.com forward slash 10 and
you can choose one of those two books,
the graveyard book bag,
a bonding or more than
180,000 audio programs.
So that could be a book. That could be
a magazine, that could be a newspaper,
could be a class. It's that easy.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim,
that's audible.com forward slash
Tim and grab a book. Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you by
a new sponsor. So listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever
wanted to be as powerful as a mullet
wearing Ninja from 1980s movie or as
flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al in south
park or as sleek as a black panther
in the Amazon on the hunt wealth?
There's great news because I've been
testing this product that you wrap around
your genitals and it makes you feel
like a superhero and it is called
[inaudible].
I've spent the last two to three weeks
traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I got to tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has giving your
groin a hug and it's not just for dudes.
But if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim, that's m, e, e, u n, d,
I e s.com forward slash Tim,
you can see all of the underwear
that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones.
And I will also highlight my favorite,
you'll probably be able
to guess which it is.
These underwear made from micro model,
which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees in the Alps. Yes, fancy.
And it's two times softer than cotton,
scientifically tested using the Calamata
method developed in Kyoto. You know,
those Japanese very crafty and uh,
I will say a few things. Number one,
if you go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash Tim,
you get to see all of these spectacular
underwear that I've been wearing.
And I am a bit of an underwear
connoisseur, socks, fashion
sense with sweatpants,
not so much underwear.
I understand.
So check them out and if you go to
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim you
will also be able to see lots
of hot ladies wearing me undies,
female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for
both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
Me undies.com forward slash Tim,
I love these underwear and a,
I'm going to be packing tonight probably
six to 12 pair to take with me to
Australia. They're great. Check em out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim.
Hello Lemurs and leprechauns.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct
world class performers,
whether they are actors
like Arnold Schwarzenegger,
military strategists or generals
like Stanley McChrystal,
chess prodigies like Josh Waitzkin
or in this particular case,
a miracle worker of sorts.
In fact you could say he
is a daredevil Wim Hoff,
otherwise known as the ice man is a
Dutch world record holder, adventurer,
certainly daredevil and he's nicknamed
the ice man for his ability to withstand
extreme cold.
He is creator of the Wim Hoff method
and holds more than 20 world records.
He is in my mind the outlier of outliers,
not because he does so many absurd things
and proves that these impossibles are
in fact possible,
but he routinely asked scientists to
scrutinize and validate these feats.
That's what makes him very,
very unique and very interesting
for this type of conversation.
What are some of his feet? Well, I'm in
2007 he climbed path, the death zone,
the altitude on Mount Everest,
which is around a 7,500 meters
wearing nothing but shorts.
2009 he completed a full marathon
above the polar circle and Finland in
temperatures close to
negative 20 degrees Celsius.
Again dressed and nothing but shorts.
He holds the Guinness World
record for the longest ice bath,
which is around at one hour, 53 minutes
and 12 seconds, but it's not just cold.
He has run full marathons in the
Namib Desert without any water.
He has also had toxins injected into
himself under doctor supervision and
demonstrated that he can effectively
control his autonomic immune response.
This is crazy talk a,
these are things that fly in the face
of many textbooks and now he is featured
in textbooks himself because he has
documented all of this and it's not just a
whim specialty, he's not a mutant. Uh,
he is able to train others to achieve
many of these same effects and abilities
in some cases with just
four days of training.
So we'll dig into all of this and more.
I loved this conversation.
He is a human Guinea pig
of human Guinea pigs.
Certainly it makes me feel like an
amateur. So without further ado,
please enjoy my
conversation with Wim Hoff.
Welcome to the show women.
I'm so pleased to have you.
Thank you for welcoming me.
Thank you very much.
I've been a fan for quite a few years
because we have, as we mentioned before,
we started recording a mutual
friend in ray crow. Nice.
And he was in my second book.
So I looked very closely at
cold exposure and of course you,
the ice man came up over and over again.
So it's really nice to
finally chat with you. It's,
I feel like it's been a long time coming
and also had to pass guests or three
past guests on this podcast, a Laird
Hamilton and Brian McKenzie and also,
um,
Gabby Reese,
Laird's wife who are big fans of your
methods and techniques who'd been
practicing it. So they are, uh, you,
you have a lot, a lot of fans out there.
I'm sure listening as well. And I
thought we could just start with, uh,
your name. I've always loved
your name. Is Wim your full name?
Yes,
I am
in does that,
it doesn't have any particular meaning
or how did your parents choose that name?
Wait,
ms,
a common name and a in
Holland in the Netherlands at,
but I looked it up and,
uh,
it says it's the protector of the people,
you know,
any name has got some logical, uh, uh,
roots to with my name is,
uh, the protector of people.
My brother's name.
Who Was it?
My twin brother is Andray Andre on phone,
say a Andrei.
Andrew.
Andrew is the protector of goods.
So who's better?
I don't know.
I suppose, I suppose you need
both types of protection, right?
You have a such a fascinating story
and you have a lot of accolades,
a lot of records. I think more than 20
world records at this point it seems,
uh, what was the first
world record that you said
at first was in Paris?
Uh,
just staying or half hour
in a immersed and ice.
And uh, 12 days later I repeated, uh, uh,
the record time.
I make it a Ma Ma made it a an
hour in a Hollywood actually.
Yes. And I saw one also, I
mean, you've, you've been,
you spend a lot of time in
ice baths and I've, uh, uh,
largely influenced by you and a
handful of other people. Tim Noakes,
ray and a huge fan of ice baths in
my fans. Always complained about it.
But I've seen you in so
many containers full of ice.
I saw one where it looks like there
was a lot of Chinese or Japanese in the
background. Uh, what is,
what has been the most
challenging cold exposure, uh,
experience that you've had,
whether it's for records or anything else?
Maybe,
uh,
losing my sight while I was
swimming underneath, Eh,
a eyes deck of a almost one
meter and I had no goggles on.
So a lot of side at 35 meters,
something like a 40 yards.
And uh, I lost the whole and uh, yeah,
I think it's like she, she had
happened, it happened over there, right.
That Meta eyes, that above. So, uh, yeah,
that was some great experience.
And another one was, uh, losing my,
uh, way, uh,
on Mount Everest in shorts and
a at a like 18,000 feet in a,
in a blizzard, in a, like a wideout.
So things like that happen. Yeah.
And uh, they are challenging,
but then it throws me back to,
you know,
the depth of myself to a, which is
trust and confidence in, I got it.
What do you say to yourself in one of
those moments? So I guess physiologically,
did your,
did your retinas just freeze or when you
were swimming under the ice deck in a
moment like that, when many people would
panic? I mean, did you panic? If, so,
what was the mental self talk when
you realize that was happening?
Very interesting. This,
the stress level at the,
at that moment is absent,
is not there.
I'm dealing with the situation. Um, Eh,
it has been shown in the
university that our stress levels,
their stress hormone levels
are able to be raised,
eh,
lying in bed more than somebody in fear
for the first time going into a bungee
jump.
Oh, go and do a better job doing a
bunch of jump for the first time.
Yeah. Yeah. But not me by because the
bang, the jump, yeah, you're attached.
But very unexpected situations in,
in nature,
like a blizzard or swimming
beneath the ice and uh,
losing a, the whole, because
your eyesight is gone.
Things like that. Or uh,
climbing without gear,
steep mountains and uh,
having cramps.
And what do you do at that moment?
That,
that's exactly what I learned,
how to raise consciously,
the stress hormone level,
purely controlled.
And I'm able to deal with the situation
at that moment without panicking.
And I think that's one of the crucial
findings which could benefit for human
mankind as it is,
you know,
a very subjected to a stress all the time.
Panicking,
having fair and all that.
And I learned in nature
how to deal with that.
And the cold brought me, uh, but uh,
brought me that science brought me
that, uh, knowledge, wisdom actually
and the, the raising
of stress hormones. So,
so controlling something that has long
been thought to be part of the autonomous
nervous system, something that
you have no control over. Right.
And we'll get to the breathing because
breathing is very interesting since it's
both autonomous,
but you can,
you can consciously control it and
practice different methods. Uh,
I think it was, it was certainly in the
vice documentary that recently came,
which I recommend to everyone and
I'll link to in the show notes,
but was it in 2011 that you were injected
with some type of virus or bacteria?
To see if you could control the
immune response that was at the Dutch.
I'm going to mispronounce this,
the Radboud University, exactly.
Wrap out to university in Holland,
a intensive care nuclear
science. I, uh, underwent a,
an experiment and they injected me with
the endo talk scene with that toxin
actually,
which is a part of a bacteria
and that creates a very dramatic,
a immune response.
And as we have no control over
the immune response in our body,
they thought I was not able to do with
as well as expected because nobody showed
to be able to serve,
press the immune response because it is
part of the autonomic nervous system.
And uh,
nobody is able to do that until now.
I showed that I was very able within
a quarter of hour instead of ours,
uh, suffering from
uncontrolled shivering, fever,
headaches and all that, uh, I
show within a quarter of our, uh,
to have a control complete
over the symptoms and uh,
also decide to kins which is our,
which are the flammatory beings and the
blood created by the immune response.
And I showed in the blood and by blood
results to suppress them dramatically,
uh, within a quarter.
Then they told me, okay,
but you are an exception that
confirms the rule because you yeah,
yeah.
You have been trainings so many years.
You are the iceman,
you do exceptional features,
but nobody is able to do that without
that proper training of so many years.
And I told him no,
I can train them within 10 days.
And then the professor was
really challenged because
if this group would show to
be able within 10 days, uh, to uh,
be able to influence deeply into the
autonomous nervous system related to the
immune system,
then that's for the first time
in the scientific history. So,
but he,
he saw the indication of the possibility
but still thought those guys are not
going to be able to do that
within 10 days. You know what,
Eh,
it wasn't within 10 days.
It wasn't with four days of training
that I made them able to undergo the same
experiments that that means that the
injection of the endotoxin and have them
within a quarter of hour
completely control over their
immune system related to
the autonomous nervous system.
So they showed a hundred percent score
of everybody to be able within a couple
of days to go to tap into the autonomous
nervous system related to the immune
system and yeah,
and the training about a
trading be a prior to it,
Eh, we add our beers,
you know, in the evening.
And there are a lot of music and
very relaxed and their mindset.
I said, I guys, uh, probably, uh, you, uh,
you guys are the new gladiators,
Eh,
where we are going to
win the worst war ever,
which, uh, produced, uh, much, uh,
the most casualties,
agony, pain and all that.
And that's the bacteria that's the back.
So that's the virus and we gonna
win this war. Are you with me?
I, that's the way I talked to
them. And so they had a mindset.
So in the evening we had a relaxed, they,
it was like a hippie movement and the,
but this is a new revolution
at in four days time.
They were able at the fourth day
without prior experience in the cold,
they were able to go in
shorts at bye bye minus stand.
That's about, I dunno, Eh,
uh, Fahrenheit Celsius.
This a selfie.
I mean it's freezing all in the twenties.
Yes, in one. And then, uh,
for hours and hours we were going up
hill and up to mountain and we arrived at
the summit after hours and it
was minus 27 minus 27 Celsius.
That that is more than a minus.
And then twenties,
it's probably 10 or so,
something like that.
And we danced to Harlem Shaygo there.
Then I knew these guys,
these guys are ready in four days time
when they will be internalized in the,
in the hospital and uh,
and injected with the endotoxin.
They will be able because I
feel when somebody is, uh,
back into its natural state of his or
hers physiology and I know how to do that,
the cold trade me, they called
is my teacher. And with the,
with the subjects, I'm so curious
to ask because, uh, the, uh,
I mean I am certainly not as proficient
as you are in any of these techniques,
but I've,
I've
enjoyed experimenting over the last
10 years in writing about these short
experiments, whether it's related to
breath holding with David Blaine or, or,
or other aspects. Um, obviously
you're a professional and I am not,
but I'm so I'd be very curious to hear
you perhaps elaborate for instance,
on the first day of training
with these subjects bef uh,
in preparation to be injected
four days later. Sure. Uh,
what did the first day of
training look like for them?
Um,
just in the morning at ease.
At eight o'clock without food intake,
we do a breathing and they
lie on the ground. Oh.
Because that's the most relaxed pose.
And uh,
if you are relaxed,
you are able to store up a hold mode.
Oh,
a lot more oxygen than when
intention or in post you.
So I say it a it just lay down and relax.
Now we are going to begin just
breathe in deeply and let go.
Breathe in deeply. Let
go, make it a rhythm.
Breathe in deeply.
Let go,
not fully out but fully and and let go.
And uh,
where you repeat that about 30,
40 times until nice indication.
So symptoms a comma by and
that it means lightheadedness.
Okay.
Loose and the body feeling loose
in the body. Tingling contractions.
That's because carbon dioxide goes out.
Oxygen is a roaming freely through
the body and the Ph levels,
rice,
they are up to me.
Lysed so they get to their
best condition and uh,
that's proven, that's
proven. And they saw a,
when we do this, uh, they, so they,
so all these results chemically then
once you feel positively charged with all
the symptoms of lightheadedness,
feeling loose,
contractions and tingling
in the buddy asked him,
just breathe in deeply, let
go. And now the last time,
breathe in deeply and had to go after
letting go after exhalations stop,
reframe from breathing.
There is no need.
We get a whole lot of oxygen and a
measurement devices are not able to detect
how much it's more than a hundred
percent that's my opinion.
But devices still are
not able to detect that.
They only can go up to a
hundred percent as an essay,
but there are a hundred the body is
able to store up more oxygen than
measurement devices have
now are able to uh, measure.
So then after one and a half minutes,
Eh,
then you see that the measurement
device shows 100% and then it goes
dramatically down afterwards.
And you're using a pulse oximeter,
like something that you clip
on your, yes, Paul's ex.
So you need a heart beat,
you have a heartbeat and you have the
saturation of the oxygen in inside the
blood.
So the amount of oxygen,
so after one and a half minute GC with
everybody that the saturation of the
blood is going down a,
you know,
people is CLPD that that's
lung diseases and all that.
They, they suffer from real severe.
See your per diem. When they have 85,
we go to 90 to 80, 70, 60,
50, people die at 50 and 40, uh,
40% saturation in the blood.
We go past,
we get, we'll go even to 30. And
then the device measurement device,
the accumulator shuts down.
It is not measuring animal,
but we even go past that one.
Now why don't you,
why don't the subjects pass out at
this point? They don't pass out,
eh, because they are
outlined. I say they're,
the Ph degrees, eh, are
really perfect at that moment.
And in,
instead of a person who's
dying is very acidic.
So that's the difference. So,
uh, because we are so alkaline,
people maybe sometimes
are able to pass out,
but just two seconds or three
seconds because they get, uh,
they are out of their conditioned control,
eh,
but, uh, in a, in a, you
know, after exercising,
they have a re a regained,
not only control in those moments
and in those situations they,
uh,
they win a new part in the brain.
They get a very deep in the
brain and it's all new terrain.
It's like baby a baby has no
problem with, uh, with our legs.
But there are no metorik
motorical neurones to the legs,
yes.
Tab.
So we are going into different
parts of the brain where there is,
where the guy or the, the, the, uh,
the girl that has been,
so it's logic that the
people are able to pass out,
but nothing happens
because they are alkaline.
So they just wake up and mostly eh,
or mostly almost always they wake up very
happy and it's like a drug experience.
So, but that's besides of
the real effect, um, uh,
trying to, uh, not, not try,
which we showed scientifically is to be
able to tap into the immune system in
all the layers.
Those are three layers and normally,
eh, we are not able to get into
the second and the third layer.
And I say,
now we have found a key to the second
and the third layer that means the
nonspecific immune system and the
specific adaptive immune system.
And that makes us looking to disease
completely different because our abilities
so much more. And, uh,
uh, we have been, um,
uh, publishing, uh, people in Boston.
They published it throughout America on
the university's chapter 22 on biology
now.
And it tells that we have tapped into
the autonomous nervous system into the
eight innate immune system,
which was up til now,
not possible.
And we did at 100% with a group of nine
people showing that they were very able
to do it,
all,
all of them within a quarter of an hour
and have spectacular results so that it
is science now and now it needs to get
to every person in the world how to tap
into the deeper layers of our
physiology without training,
you know,
years and years and years and
being Joe Gibbs or being a,
the super athletes and all that,
no,
my aim within a couple of days,
we are all able to tap into the deepest
layers of our physiology and reset our
immune system,
bring it under our will and that's my aim.
But then we make farm to and all that.
But for say being serious,
that's my goal.
Right. No, I was just going to say,
I mean it's very hard to get the,
I think you're approaching it in a
very intelligent way because it's,
it's very hard to get truly serious work
done if you're serious all the time.
So yeah,
I enjoy it.
It's very fascinating for me as a teacher
to watch how you coach your subjects
because you use beer,
you have guitar and uh,
I think it's very important component.
Um, it, it would seem to be,
and I wanted to ask you about the
breathing on day one, just one more time,
which is,
is,
is the breathing exercise
on day one something that
then the subjects use during
the injection or before the injection or
is it an exercise to prove to them that
they can do more than they think they
can do and it's more of a confidence
builder that you use to set the
tone for the rest of the training?
Yes.
So it's a confidence builder and is very
effective at the moment when something,
uh,
like an injection has come in and they
know it will result in dramatic a immune
response and they have to build up
and make alert their shield or are
protective, uh, uh, alliance of, uh,
of defense, which is the immune
system. Yes. So both, both.
And is this something that you can do
after the fact? So for instance, uh,
at this point with your, uh,
your level of proficiency,
if you were to contract a disease
without realizing it and then to get very
sick,
would you be able to reverse that or
is it something that needs to be a,
is that she,
does the shield need to
be activated beforehand in
order for you to control that
autonomous,
so-called autonomous response?
Interesting.
Very nice.
[inaudible] it's both
preventive and healing.
So once a specific hormone or a
molecule must be generated to get to a,
an uh,
an,
an invader nonself invader in the body,
which could be a bacteria,
a virus, or a back sell,
which got through the
first two lines of defense.
Then the third line is more specific,
but it takes normally like weeks or
sometimes it's not traceable because uh,
Eh, an invader is mutated. But uh,
we have now,
uh,
a method that is able to tap into the
third layer and make the nuns are the
specific adaptive immune system,
uh,
rapidly active even
after something comes in.
So it's both a preventive,
uh,
but is also when you feel you become sick,
so a,
an invader has gotten in then you are
still a very able to restore the balance
with it. Got It. Yes.
And um, the, if we're looking at the,
the explanation that the scientists have
at this point for your ability and your
subject's ability to protect
themselves or shield themselves, uh,
it seemed like one hypothesis was
you being able to increase I think
noradrenaline or norepinephrine
levels in the body. Uh,
do you agree with that or do
you think there are other, uh,
do you have other series?
I
do, I do. I'd love to hear it.
It's like if you have HIV and I'm,
the immune system is still looking
for answers up till a moment.
That it is not able to specify
anymore what's going on.
And then we get aids, eh, that,
that means that all the
defense systems are shut down.
Now we have shown by nor a
benefit print and no adrenaline,
adrenaline, eh, that we can, uh, uh,
suppress the inflammation that means
the flammatory bodies and creating an
immune response and we suppressed it.
That would be like a shutting down
the immune system that makes us,
uh,
following the scientific logic
that makes us more vulnerable.
No what we do.
And they still got to find out.
But I just use my natural logic
and you can read a poem in the,
in the, in the, in the papers
that we have found a way
to awaken the third line,
which normally takes weeks or months to,
uh,
to, uh, find the specific hormone
or molecule, which Dan is,
uh, going, uh, for,
or the target cell to go
on the membrane and to Eh,
kill this out. So That's interesting. It's
almost like internal drug development.
You're trying to find the lock that, I'm
sorry, the key that fits the proper lock,
but you're doing it internally.
Yeah.
Normally it takes a very long
time biologically to, to,
to uh, sort of, uh, to conclude with. But
you're accelerating that process. Exactly.
Yeah.
And then days our bones are not needed
anymore because there's specific hormone,
there's specific,
a molecule gets on the cell
membrane and then all this, uh,
uh, like fire, uh, people, uh,
which is nor adrenaline gets through out
the system and a pen offering as well.
And they suppress the
inflammation, the action. And uh,
but that is only possible when the
target is already a annihilated when the
target has a specific molecule on it
because of the third line of defense.
Right. And that's that,
that's what we found.
We found a way and its ultimate Dr
Kevin Tracey from Manhasset New York who
tells them he is very much easier
now authority in the biochemistry.
And uh,
I worked with him in 2007 and I showed,
I was able in is a institute,
uh,
to suppress or to
influence the vague nerve,
which is the Vegas nerve.
Yeah. Yes. And now, uh,
he told in nature,
he told immunity does not
come without neuro regulation.
They found a way.
So what do you now, for
instance, I was a, I did my, uh,
undergraduate for a very
short period of time. Uh,
in college I studied neuroscience.
And I remember when I was in college,
there was a professor there who
determined that for instance,
the neurons in the hippocampus
could actually be regenerated.
And this was very,
very big,
big news because people had assumed for
a very long time in a number of parts of
the brain that neurons could not
be degenerated or regenerated.
Basically as you got older,
you just lost neuro neuronal function
and it could not be restored.
Now we know that's not true.
Right? And so you're having this,
a similar experience where you are
proving to people that things are possible
that were thought impossible.
What, what do you think,
what other impossibles do you think we
will prove our possible in the next say,
five years in your kind of
area of experimentation?
Very, very nice. A very good question. Uh,
I think depression for example,
and the brace itself and we are able to
tap into the brain's and do so much more
influence. So much more, uh, uh,
which is related to the
hypothalamus and the pineal gland,
the pituitary gland, the hippocampus
and the Amygdala, the seed of emotion.
All these are part and
around the brainstem,
which is the reptilian brain,
the primitive brain.
And because of our comfort
way of living and behavior,
Eh, this part doesn't
get enough a stimulation,
right? Got untrained. Yes.
That doesn't get the
stimulation nor oxygen.
So there is a certain kind of
deregulating p h level we are going on.
It's just to a lack of oxygen.
There is no action, no stimulation.
So in time it begins to malfunction.
And that's uh,
yeah, that's actually a,
yeah, sort of a logic.
So we suffer from a whole lot par example
of depression in the Western world
because, uh, because we
go too much into, uh, the,
the NEOCORTEX, the, the
superficial brain, the new brain,
and we have to do all kinds of things
and that at that lines and worries and we
cannot stop it and it
consumes all the energy.
What I do and learn is to
go into the brainstem again.
They said that the simplicity
of our reptilian brain,
the primitive brain,
the brainstem,
which is related to all these
beautiful eh, glance over that,
which is the pineal gland, pituitary
gland and the, and the controller of ours,
which is the hypothalamus and
the seat of emotion itself,
which is the Amygdala.
It's all there.
And so I found a way to get into that
and show just by this example of hours to
lying in bed,
people are able to produce more adrenaline
than somebody who is in fear going
into a bungee jump for the first time.
You see what I mean?
That that means fair emotion,
uncontrollable emotions and fear.
We are able to control that.
And that's because we tap controlled
into the brainstem and produce any
adrenaline or epinephrine
or, uh, all these,
all these, uh, uh, gland, uh,
now not plants hormones we need.
And it's the pineal gland
in the, in the finally, uh,
which is the control of all
the other glands in our body.
So we are able now to tap into that.
So the coming five years,
I want to eradicate a depression.
I want to eradicate,
Eh, the, the, Eh, yeah,
actually a disease.
I know a big words, but we are
into that. I'm not only into,
that is a also professors,
biochemists who stamp my point
and they see it's so simple,
so accessible and so effective.
But it needs to be translated into our
infrastructure of a thinking as well as
of interests.
But it needs to cooperate with schooling.
Now we got on a university that's nice.
It's coming top down because our,
if the US universities are
taking it on than soon,
all the universities and
the world will follow.
So we find the, okay,
I rest my 0.4 for now
and with the, uh, so with,
for instance, depression.
So there, I'm sure there are a lot
of people listening who have, uh,
bouts with depression or
even extended depression.
Yes. No control over their mood,
right? No control over the brainstem.
Right?
So let's break it back to the brainstem,
right? So, for instance, you know,
I find that it's very helpful for
me at least to use cold exposure.
And whether that's cold
showers or ice bath, uh, it
has a tremendous mood
elevating effect or maybe mood,
a balancing effect that depending
on on how we want to explain it.
But for someone who is feeling depressed,
what are some simple things that you
would recommend that they try potentially
get into conscious breathing,
deeper breathing,
and be consciously doing that?
Uh,
it showed in the university
that I was able just, you know,
about consciousness just by thinking
that I was going into an experiment.
I raised sell on cell level,
the metabolic activity in the cell with
300% just by thinking that our minds,
so our mind should be with
people who are depressed.
They just got lost.
They have no control.
So they have to regain control by
consciously going into breathing.
Breathing brings about deeper breathing,
uh,
brings about a better ph level in
the body, but not only in the body.
Also in the mind and the,
Eh,
the right Ph level will
make the neurotransmitters.
That's your mind, eh,
electrical signals, finally,
uh,
work better.
And then you are able to do or learn
to direct these neurotransmitters or
thoughts the mind itself,
uh,
consciously with the
right Ph degree. So, Eh,
we make it simple and we say conscious
breathing all the time cause you lost
track and it takes energy.
It takes your mind and you got to bring
back your mind under your control.
And uh,
I mean this I think is related to a
broader topic of compulsive behavior,
right?
Or people who have automatic
behaviors that are not serving them.
And one of those is oftentimes
eating or overeating.
And before we started recording,
I asked you what you had for breakfast
and he said nothing because you eat once
per day. So I could you describe
what your daily eating ritual is?
I eat after six o'clock in the afternoon
and that's already for 35 years.
And there is,
I got a lot of energy and you know
why you have a lot of allergies now?
Energy. Oh, I'm sorry. Sorry. Cut It.
Maybe allergies as well. Women, you know,
uh, okay, just to make fine.
Thank you. And I have to have
wine next time we do this thing.
He's very outdated. How
are you? Good. Uh, Eh,
the thing is by better
breathing conscious breathing,
you made this chemical process in the,
in the cell happened,
which is called aerobic dissimilation.
And as a,
in the cell production to make energy,
mitochondrial energy,
you need food.
But if you are able to
influence by better breathing,
a deeper breathing,
then you produce simple metabolic
activity in the Mitochondria by better
breathing.
And that creates energy,
which was the purpose of food.
So food is nice. Hello? I'm here.
Oh yeah, food is nice. Food is great.
You should do it with a lot of love and
they're having a nice time making it and
the, because that's the energy
you get finally a altar,
but eh, Eh, Eh, like uh, me, uh,
uh,
it's a sort of a fast,
but I have to feel your hear
the scientists really gets,
are going to be much more effective and
the cell activity is going to be much
more effective and it is using all the
food and you can eat after six o'clock.
I can eat what I want the
other day I'm slim again.
And that's making, you
know, making the bodywork.
But as we eat all the day long,
the body is not shutting down.
It's not effective.
Animal doesn't go deep,
doesn't go into survival mode
is it's not natural again.
So it's beginning to store up all the
fats because it doesn't know what to do
anymore because the deeper mechanisms
are not working anymore. So.
Yeah.
And how to bring that.
And what do you usually,
what do,
what are some typical meals
that you have after 6:00 PM
that uh, uh, I like pasta
and I like a couple of beers too.
Yeah,
sounds good. I, uh, the eating
rituals are interesting.
I've interviewed a number of people on
this podcast including General Stanley
McChrystal is a four star general
and he was, he's also famous for, um,
getting a lot of exercise early in
the day and eating one meal per day.
He's also, he's also very
well known for that. Uh, you,
you described the breathing exercise,
uh,
some of the breathing
exercises that you do.
Does the type of breathing
that you do have anything, uh,
is it similar in any ways to holotropic
breathwork? If you're familiar with that?
And I heard from someone,
and maybe you can correct me if I'm wrong,
that some scientists had looked at,
at whether were
producing or releasing more
DMT during some of your,
uh,
breathing activities.
Is that accurate or did I get
some misinformation from someone?
I'll just be very,
no, that's a professor who, right. Yeah.
I don't know. A Colorado, I don't know.
Uh, what is his name again? I don't,
I use a, I told her the, in the field,
but I had a dialogue with
him and he is talking about,
uh, uh, you know,
I a whiskey guy on the old drugs
and all this and experimenting.
And I said,
I told him I'm able to produce Eh,
to Eh,
trigger the pineal gland in
a way that DMT is released.
And uh, and yes, I can make
people very, very happy,
uh, doing, uh, oh, all these
breathing exercises that that's true.
But the purpose of DMT actually is to
work out the subconscious wild dreaming.
And the rapid eye movement
sleep and the other one is, uh,
when you die,
then DMT is released as well as
to make it more a Yanno happy,
uh, going after, uh, having a, have a,
have a nice time zone to the other side,
something like that.
So there is a natural purpose for DMT,
but we are,
we are very,
I'm very able to trigger that a,
that creates a DMT.
And I told him,
I told him [inaudible] it's
not only about the DMT,
which is very nice, it's a
nice drug and all that. But uh,
the better part of it
is if we are able to,
to trigger the pineal gland,
which is related directly to the
hypothalamus and the pituitary gland.
If we are able to trigger that one and
to decalcify because of our comfort way
of living, uh, the, this pineal gland,
then this gland is able to,
to direct all the other glands.
It's the only gland that is directing
all the other glands and we can bring,
we can narrowly connect with it
without our neocortex is what we do.
And it shows them that we are able to
prevent from disease or bacteria coming in
because we are able to
activate it much more directly.
Um, um, the, that's the main
purpose to, Ya know, uh,
looking different at what creates disease
is because of our pineal gland or the
brainstem is not really active animal
because it's neglected because of a
comfort style of living and behavior.
And we want to make a shortcut
and to show it that it is simple,
accessible and effective.
Well, I think the, the, the,
the comfort is important to underscore
because I was having a conversation with
Dean Karnazes several years ago.
He's a famous ultra marathoner.
You guys would probably have a lot
to talk about it. And uh, he, he, uh,
he ran need a 50 marathons in 50 days in
50 states. He's one of those guys. And,
um, he said that, uh,
he lives in northern California near San
Francisco where I live and he's in one
of his lines and I'm, I'm, I might be
paraphrasing this, but he said, you know,
people now they confuse being happy with
being comfortable and they think being
comfortable is being happy, but that's,
those are not the same thing. And, uh,
I'd like to talk about discomfort for
a second. So you ran a marathon in,
was it death valley with no water?
Yes. Yeah. And that may be, yeah,
Namibia. That's right. Even so,
even more dangerous because
you have snakes and whatnot.
So is it possible to not,
so of course,
when you are submerged in ice,
it's been demonstrated that you can
maintain your core body temperature for a
very long period of time.
Uh,
is it possible for you to drop your body
temperature in a hot climate or have
you just,
is it training yourself to
withstand the higher temperatures?
Yeah, that's exactly a boat. Actually.
Your tolerance is rising and that means
you are able to endure a whole lot more
because you're able to
influence their hormonal system.
In a way that neutralizes pain signals.
That's one. The other one is, uh,
because of my training in the cold,
I not only trained in Nicole,
I trained to endure impact of temperature
and those are receptors of hours which
I've trained.
And then because of that,
which is part which is
controlled by the Hypothalamus,
is the thermal regulator of our body.
And uh,
because I trained in the cold,
I trained the thermo regulation
of the body then without training,
without training,
a meter of running and then not drinking
a full marathon in the Namib desert,
the eat without prior training
or ever been there before.
Uh, I was very able to do that
because this thermal regulative,
uh, mechanism, the
hypothalamus I had trained in,
uh, in, in the call, which
is the temperature impact.
So I learned to deal with the
temperature and you know, what,
and not only the temperature,
which is cold and heat,
but also that prevention of oxygen.
That means going up mount
Everest and shorts at that means,
eh,
very cold out there.
There is no oxygen and you need
oxygen to and for combustion in the,
in the cell to create heat
energy and there is no oxygen.
So I learned in the cold how to deal with
impact on the barrel nervous system on
our metabolism.
That means cold deprivation of oxygen,
a heat,
but also stress daily stress.
So the secret of our comfort as you say,
and the people they are confusing,
uh, like the paraphrasing this,
this, this great guy, uh, of uh,
northern California who is telling
the truth. We are confused.
We don't know animal what real confidence.
Real confidence is the power to regulate.
Uh,
all the impacts existence in,
in life.
That means disease,
which has impact on our body.
Heat,
cold deprivation of oxygen,
stress in general,
any stress. And we are able to
control that a whole lot more.
And that brings about the real comfort
because if you connect yourself with all
these older systems within,
then you feel really good,
real good.
It's real connection and that at that,
that's something be ago.
That's why all these outdoor freaks and
the idiots and at teatro like myself are
doing this because we just feel good.
Well,
it seems like it's also a feeling
comfort is in a way becoming competent in
discomfort, right? So you,
you have a confidence that you can handle
and adapt to whatever's going to come
your way. A much like some
of the, I suppose, you know,
elite military that I've met who are
or were very actually very relaxed.
I mean the most,
most of the high level guys I've met
because they've systematically exposed
themselves to discomfort so they don't
fear discomfort, if that makes sense.
All right.
Secondly, they control their stress
hormone release completely, right?
That's what I'm talking about.
Now. You speak, how many
languages do you speak,
Ken?
10 that is a lot of languages.
How did you learn that many languages?
Just be open and love
to learn and that's it.
I had no real teachers then,
you know,
people in the street and sometimes
had to look for a teacher,
like a Japanese teacher or,
uh,
they were in the Amsterdam and the
Hindu teacher pounded. And, uh, so,
uh, yeah. Uh, I was just interested.
You are interested in life.
You get to know and the never
stop learning because you love it.
Is there is what language of
all the languages you've tried,
what was the hardest for you Horace?
Maybe Polish,
Polish shoes because it's a complete
different set of a grammatical structures.
I see.
Polish and Nostrovia I guess I have.
I bet you know that one. Yeah. Yeah.
We definitely have to have a round two
with some, with some wine and beer.
But the, um, the next question
I'd love to ask is, uh,
perhaps a simple one,
but why are people fat and how can
people develop more brown fat and use it
effectively?
Yes.
People are being fat because it's
a protective mechanism of the,
of our bodies.
It's actually in an answer to,
to own too much impact,
too much wrong chemistry going on.
So it wants to make an
installation that's a,
that's a natural thing to do of the body.
Now we are suffering from that.
Now it's called obesity and being
overweight and we have no control.
Just bringing them back to the
control. How do we do that? By, by,
by this adipose Bra,
Brown fat adipose,
because they have a,
mostly of those people,
I have also an absence of
brown fat because they are,
have no stimulation
anymore for longer time.
And then there's insulation.
A reflex is beginning
to build up a mailed up,
but actually the is telling,
Hey guy,
I'm trying to do my best for you,
but you are not doing anything in return.
And as long as you're not triggering or
stimulating the adipose, the brown fat,
then it circums it goes away. And, and,
and that it is not able to, uh, to uh, uh,
uh, to divert a white fat
into energy anymore. Right?
So it's gone with people with obesity,
they have no brown fat animal.
So there is a logic explanation
to it and I know it,
so they have to bring it back.
And it's that whole
exposure primarily that would
be the first step to try to cold
cold exposure.
And that's real exposure to the elements.
That's one in an adaptive way,
gradual way.
I mean that we are able to adapt to it,
but as these mechanisms are not working
really well within these people,
so they have to be very uh,
sensitive and,
and uh, uh, gradual or going into it.
And the reading,
breathing is chemistry is yeah.
Is
influencing the chemistry right
here, right now. Better breathing,
deeper breathing brings about
better ph degree in the body,
which then finally result
in a faster metabolism.
And if people are practicing
this or want to pack,
practice this breathing on their own,
is there any particular mantra or
anything they should focus on or say to
themselves as they're doing this? Is any
type of meditation okay. To start with?
Like using an app like headspace
or calm or do you have a particular
recommendation? If someone
said, I have 10 minutes a day,
I'm willing to spend doing this.
Um, what would you say to them?
Yeah,
just have you a favorite music going on.
Go really into it and go really into the
breathing because it's about chemical
changes and whenever you hear the right
music you are able to relax more and
more. Auctions in Dan is
able to get into the body,
which is finally changing the,
the Ph levels in the body, uh,
to the, to its natural state.
That's what we have
because we live in such a
compressed society, uh, uh,
too much stress going on.
We do not have control of the stress
we get out of our natural state.
So within 10 minutes we are,
I say within four minutes,
just do this breathing exercise,
which I teach people and do pushups,
pushups without air in the lungs.
You should do that.
So you do that after the,
after the exhale.
Yes. After, yeah, first year do like 30,
like I explained deeply within,
go deeply with him,
Eh, look at her indications, uh,
feel feeling loose in the
body and lightheaded, uh,
contractions a little bit
tingling, that's all. Okay.
Like 30 or 40 deep breaths
and then letting go 40 times.
Then you will arrive at that being charged
with a oxygen and carbon dioxide gas
got awake,
Ph levels gotten up.
Then you shoot breathing fully
laughingo glow after exhalation,
you stop and you go do
pushups and you will see,
you are able to do more pushups without
air in the lungs because she influenced
into the chemistry.
Hmm. That's end, uh, probably a good
idea to do on a soft surface first
just in case he decided to kiss
the floor a little too hard.
Now this is something that,
uh,
that layered in his guys had
been working on as well. I mean,
a lot of these guys are working in
doing pushups or stationary bike.
Very interesting. They have free divers
that, uh, there's sometimes work out with.
It's very fascinating. Great.
Well I'm going to try that.
I would love to switch gears just a
little bit and ask you a couple rapid
questions.
You can certainly take your time.
It doesn't mean you have to
answer them quickly, but, uh, the,
the first is when you think
of the word successful,
who is the first person
who comes to mind for you?
The heart.
That heart in any person that,
that, that that's success.
I'm further maybe Mandela.
Nelson Mandela. Yes.
And, and with the heart,
if someone feels like if
someone doesn't feel successful,
uh, what would you, what would your
advice be to them? Or what would you,
what would you say to them?
Yeah, just do the method. I
mean, there's Methodist, Sherwin,
scientifically to be able to tap into
the deepest of our physiology if somebody
feels he's frustrated is because he is
not able to tap in his or hers physiology
at the deepest. He has no control.
That makes people frustrated.
And we, uh, we,
we mirror that with society and all that.
But you got your vehicle.
If you are able to steer your vehicle,
your body, your mind to
work, whatever you feel,
then you will be successful. So any, yes,
I'm sorry to interrupt. I was just going
to ask him why Nelson Mandela. Yeah.
Ah, yeah, he's just a good
guy. He was always smiling.
He loved the women and uh,
he stayed like 25 years
believing in this case.
And that makes him, for
me really strong. And, uh,
I love people who have faith simply
because that's what they feel.
And yes, I, uh, I've been,
uh,
so,
so many years the galactic and
mock to mock and all that, but uh,
always had my faith and now it is science
for the same like 20 years ago they
told me, you're crazy. You're an idiot.
You're a lunatic and all that. Yes.
And even my, in my family, I was the
black sheep and right now I'm the,
why does sheep,
so it's a lot of hypocrisy going on in
the world because people do not know.
But I got my faith,
I got my belief and I want to go up till
the point that we scientifically showed
everybody is able to tap in.
It's a endocrine system,
eh,
so much that depression and being unhappy
and being frustrated is no longer part
of humanity.
It's a choice.
No, this was, uh, this
is a topic I, I'd be,
I think we could talk
about it for a long time.
What is your favorite book or the book
that you've given to other people the
most as a gift?
Whoa.
Never gave many books
except for the books are right, right.
What do you give to people as gifts?
What do you like to give people as gifts?
Oh, as stones, stones, a lot
of sat and natural things.
I get people in the natural things.
I collected a whole bunch of things
and then two months later I'm,
I'm fed up with the thing and then I
take this one, wants to go with him.
And those are beautiful stones.
When I told them the first time
I got great stone. Beautiful. Oh,
this a artifact. Well,
what your aid. Wow. Nice.
Then two months later it's gone,
you know? Then I just gave it away.
Add. So, Eh, with books,
the same thing as see darker,
see data.
And Jonathan Livingston Seagull
comes to my mind and that's okay.
And some scriptures I read about the
Bhagavad Gita and the Bible of course,
Ebay,
all these books.
I was reading hundreds of books and uh,
at a certain point I could not make
the connection with my deepest within
myself, which was the
seeker. I was sold searching.
And I found it finally in the open book
of the ice water because the ice water
is merciless but righteous.
It brings you just within and uh,
there is no,
uh,
there is no chit chatting around
that there's no philosophy.
You just do it right or you do it wrong.
Now you've had of course, some,
some very challenging times.
Um, perhaps more so than
many people I've spoken with.
You had very tragic premature
death it with your wife.
In the case of your wife,
what do you do to,
to overcome those dark
periods? Yes, very uh,
very good, very interesting.
Very real and deep. God, uh,
losing, uh, the person you love.
I have four children with her.
They work with me and uh,
right now they are like 33 years old,
the oldest one and then two
daughters and another son.
And they all work with me right now.
Oh,
actually one is working right now at
the Dutch embassy in Washington DC in
America. But the rest is
working with me all the time.
So losing the love of your life,
how deep can you go?
And being ted apart,
that was what I was experienced
at the time. But then,
Eh, I was the only person
who was, uh, re, uh, Ooh,
I was alone and I had to raise four
kids alone and that they were like seven
years old, eight years,
nine years and 11 years.
And I had to raise them alone.
So I received so much love, Eh,
of, of my kids. And I did my training.
And as I told you, Eh, the,
the brainstem is alter the
area of the seat of emotion,
which is the Amygdala.
And because of this training in the cold,
I could control silence myself and go on
and always find the energy to go on and
to be a father happy and
exercising and practical and uh,
with my kids. And uh, they
gave me a lot of love.
But
the thing about grief and the emotion is
you have to go deep because emotion is
going deep. And as we live in the
comfort zone, we have no control,
mostly over emotion.
And I tell you there is a way to,
uh,
control the seat of emotion,
which is the Amygdala connected to
the, uh, in the area of the brain stem.
So I think this, uh, uh,
not think my experience
tells me discipline,
discipline and believing,
believing within there
is a weight to silence,
a grieved,
broken hearts,
grieve and Burt emotions.
Yes,
it's a,
it's a way did it
and the, um, it's, it's really been
fascinating for me to observe a,
a number of people,
I won't mention some of the other names,
but who have used specifically,
uh,
exposure to the cold too.
I suppose the purity of that cold and
the attention that requires a sort of
purity of attention that it requires to
overcome very dark periods or be to act
as a very strong component for passing
through those difficult periods. It's,
it's just a,
it's a very fascinating pattern that
I've observed in a number of my,
a number of my friends.
Uh, I recognize what is,
what is your morning, the first
60 minutes of your day look like?
When do you wake up?
What do you do in those first 60 minutes
if you have complete control over that
morning
was time to get into conscious breathing,
where consciously
breathe when you wake up.
And your setup is all about vital for us,
created by oxygen.
It's for free and it's there
and I said it's to me it's so,
it's God itself, they'll like
for Noma, the vital force,
the Prana,
it's all a different names of
God and they tell all the uh,
the,
the uh,
belief systems still that that's the
vital for us of any off of life itself.
So that's the, that's a
very logic, natural way.
I begin brief
still still laying in bed.
Yeah, still laying in
bed and then uh, to uh,
doing the exercise,
uh,
which I explained prior in this interview.
Uh,
it is,
yeah,
it is very nice because you are still
very relaxed and about the body is without
tension.
So you then are able to go
tap deeply into the system.
And how long will you do
that in bed typically?
Yeah,
it's a stay a half hour,
something like that before going into
action could be an hour because it's
never,
never boring.
What would you say to someone who says,
you know,
actually I find it really boring. I'm
not saying that I feel that way, but if,
if someone felt boring,
what would you,
what would you advise them
or what would you tell them?
It's [inaudible] once again, the same
thing as this California and a great guy,
Dean, Dean. Dean Cortez. Yeah.
The income assets and they don't
know what come for this all about.
So,
uh,
going d just by breathing into
the depth of our physiology,
it's like Galen,
the aim of all those people going
into outdoor or taking drugs or eh,
doing extremes or a goal for a rush.
Now you can our age old to learn,
to control the depth of your physiology
by just breathing properly and going
into that system.
And a boring is something if you are doing
things repetitiously but not breaking
through the conditioning.
And I learned to go
through the conditioning,
right? So if you have to be
conscious about the activity,
you can't be daydreaming.
It's,
it seems you just have to be attentive
to your breathing when you're doing
something like this.
Yes, yes. Just go into it.
It's like the past meditation.
That's what they do.
They sit and they just
listen and focus on grieving.
That's all at what I do.
And they get into a deeper layer of
their brain because they are not giving
their focus to something else
than just mayor breathing.
It is so simple,
but so effective.
I'll try that tomorrow morning. The, so
let's say you do that for a half hour,
then what do you do
for the next half hour?
Um,
nowadays I do a lot to do with a lot
of workshops and lectures and then,
uh, into science. But yeah, uh,
for in between I do exercising.
I like exercising.
What type of exercise do you,
if you had to choose one type of exercise
are two types of exercise for yourself,
what would you choose?
A strength and flexibility.
What would you do for both of those
as strength? Power
example, stay on two arms.
Save four minutes like a planet or just
different types of poses onto our mat
with one hand or to a
plank or a handstands or,
uh, pullups pushups of course,
eh, those, uh, you know,
power exercises or stand in
a horse stance for an hour.
That is sometimes just to with stones in
my hands and I make all kinds of food,
like, uh, movements,
just make them up and,
but you know,
to battle my aesthetic,
the aesthetic processes in my body.
So I go deeply into the horse stance
and breathe in a way that a acid is not
[inaudible] in the body. So that makes
me control the body and uh, yeah,
it feels good. And then
for flexibility, yeah,
all kinds of splits and then put a
couple of lags and Maya behind my head,
the things, you know, uh,
do balancing a exercises.
It's nice. Uh, Eh, I, I
maintained the body that way.
What do you listen to music when you're
exercising or do you do without music?
I simply have no record
system. So, but eh, Eh,
right now I'm a w we bought a center.
So I will have my big doe,
Joe and a Whoa.
A cascade and all that,
and a swimming pool and all those things.
And that I will have the right
music and make music myself. I,
uh,
I played the guitar,
I saying I want to make a CD very soon.
And people like me singing,
uh,
doing all kinds of mantras because I,
you know,
learned about the sunscreen
and a Spanish songs,
a English songs and all kinds of songs.
I just make up my sort of a wrapper
too. So. Yeah, I'd love
to hear it. And what, uh,
what musician do you look up to the most?
Is there a particular musician that you
admire that you would like to emulate or
look up?
I like a lot, a lot, a lot
of lounge, EH, easy music.
I like Michael Jackson. Michael
Jackson's great. Yeah, he is a fit.
Do you have a favorite song or a favorite
album? Uh, of, of uh, Michael Jackson?
Yes. Yeah, all the songs. This is it,
for example, it's a great oh
yeah, great deal is great.
And his voice is mass Merrick.
Oh yeah, totally. Yeah.
Yeah.
So I uh,
get my son his name,
which is Michael,
which is one of my songs.
So things like that,
but also pink Floyd, also Gypsy
kings, you know, plumbing,
Flamenco and all the goop music and
there's a lot of good music going on
and uh, yes, I can't wait to
visit the, uh, the center.
Is that going to be in Holland?
Yes. Okay. For now, I
would say in Holland,
I was looking to make a center in
the near San Francisco as well.
I get some very good friends over there.
You should, you should,
you should come up.
Maybe we'll do a workshop
and I could introduce you
to, I'll invite Dean as well.
You could meet dean. Yes. Yes.
He's a great guy. He's a great guy.
He would love to meet you. I'm sure.
The, just a few more questions.
I want to be obviously respectful
of your time. What, uh,
what purchase in the last, you know,
six months or a year of less than $100.
So something you bought for less than
$100 has most positively impacted your
life. Stones, stones. I love these stones.
I want to talk about.
So how do you find these stones
and what makes you pick one? Uh,
do you have any favorites?
I always take a stones out.
Whatever touches matter meets the eye.
Uh,
I take them from the
mountains had climbed,
but I also like these tests and
a old pills and all kinds of,
you know, beautiful stones where the
beautiful colors. I like that. But uh,
yeah, I always take
stones from the uh, uh,
I just found a big for sale in the,
in the Spanish period.
Knees, you know, big,
big means like two to three kilos.
That's a big, big bottle
there and forced out. And uh,
and uh, I couldn't get it down because
a, it was there where the group,
the ad, the ad, no, a backpack.
And I had to carry the ropes because
we were doing canyon and all that.
So, but, uh, there was a girl
from Austin, Texas, Austin,
Elizabeth Lee, and she
had a backpack. And See,
she carried it there for me. It's a good
friend. Yeah. Always. Yeah. I love it.
Yeah. Yeah. So the what,
what effect do, and did you,
do you put that in your kitchen?
Where do you put such a,
such a stone and what
effect does it have on you?
Everywhere they, they have a
solid I've hacked is hey, yeah,
simply there and they are beautiful and
I always pass them on to other people
except for the big ones.
What, uh, what advice would
you give your 30 year old self?
My 30th and just have faith.
Have faith.
Faith.
Yes.
What type of faith that things will
work out? The things will be okay.
[inaudible] simple logic,
half simple logic and understanding I
things simply and, and listen to you.
You're feeling listened to.
You're feeling,
you're feeling it knows it.
It is simply sense making and that if you
are letting it in your way of thinking
and never lose track of whatever
makes sense, which is feeling,
which is instinct and intuition.
Right,
right.
This is something I've been trying to
work on a lot because it's easy for me at
least to get trapped in my neocortex to
get trapped exactly in the front of my
brain where I can make pro and con lists.
But the answer is so obvious sometimes
because you know that something's wrong
or you know that someone isn't a good
fit or you don't trust someone just like,
yeah,
you have that feeling like a dog.
Where are you immediately either
like or dislike something? Yes. It's,
I've been trying to train myself to
go back to that simplicity. It's,
I'm making sense. It can
be challenging. Yeah.
So what one or two more questions, the,
if, if you could have one billboard,
one huge sign anywhere
with anything on it, uh,
what would it say and
where would you put it?
I would say a brief motherfucker.
Okay.
You could put that on like a busy highway.
You can put that on like sunset
boulevard in Los Angeles. Or
I got maybe a brief, a, Eh, you know,
I don't know why their way day. I noticed
that it, but it's really meant lovable.
Right.
And you know which strength is the
answer to the APP till the DNA itself.
And it's not me telling that anymore
because of the blood results.
Professors have confirmed that
we are in the middle of DNA.
And what is the trigger breathing?
So this is a, so you could,
you could have it say breathe,
breathe motherfucker within a smiley,
a smiley face, like a smiley emoticon.
That'd be perfect.
Yes. It's, so we got a t shirt at,
says I'm the front please.
You know,
it's about the cold enough and that the
other side is Britain. Motherfucker.
Oh well you and I need to hang out more.
I uh, this is, this has been great. Uh,
of course everybody listening.
I'm going to put tons of
links in the show notes.
You should check out iceman,
Wim Hoff, w. I. M. H. O. F. Uh,
definitely check out Wim Hoff method and
I'll link to that in the show notes. Uh,
is a 10 week online video course,
which a bunch of people whose names
you would know are using right now.
It's very,
very interesting and there are bunch of
documentaries and links to the textbooks
I will include as well.
Um,
when do you have any last requests
or asks of my audience there?
There are a lot of people
who will be hearing this.
If you could ask them all to do something.
Um,
besides checkout the courses and so on.
What, what would you ask them to do?
Something they could do when they
hear this or after they hear it?
Yeah, just pass it on grief. That's one.
And take a cold shower after a hot word
and it just get into the science of
this. Oh, it is non speculative.
And for the rest I just love you guys.
Well when this is wonderful,
everybody listening,
I will link to all these things you
can find whim on Twitter at ice,
man underscore Hoff h o f and
I'll link to that Instagram,
same iceman underscore Hoff.
Facebook is facebook.com,
forward slash becoming
the ice man and a women.
Thank you so much for taking the time.
This was a blast.
Thank you very much. I hear
soulmates. I thank you very much.
And I love you very much.
Greetings to uh, re Cron ass.
Definitely talk to him.
Be I will a male. Um,
also he loves you and you your work.
He loves my work.
You know,
we like to work to make love happen.
Definitely. Well, uh, we will uh,
we'll play some guitar and have
some wine and you can uh, oh yeah,
I would love to.
I would love to get into some shorts and
a and freeze my ass off and breath at
some points up and write it
up in the mountains. That
would be a, that'd be great.
So until next time, thank you everybody
for listening and when thanks so much.
Great.
Thank you very much to
hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more
soul of fun before the weekend.
And five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the, uh, the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com.
That's four hour workweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next
one. And if sign up, I hope
you enjoy it. This episode is brought to
you by a new sponsor. So listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever
wanted to be as powerful as a bullet
wearing Ninja from 1980s movie or as
flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al in south
park or a sleek as a black panther
and the Amazon on the hunt wealth?
There's great news because I've been
testing this product that you wrap around
your genitals and it makes you feel
like a superhero and it is called
[inaudible].
I've spent the last two to three weeks
traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I got to tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has giving your
groin a hug and it's not just for dudes,
but if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim, that's Emma, e,
u n d I e s.com forward slash.
Tim,
you can see all of the underwear
that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones
and I will also highlight my favorite.
You'll probably be able
to guess which it is.
These underwear made from micro model,
which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees and the Alps. Yes,
fancy and it's two times
softer than cotton.
Scientifically tested using the Calamata
method developed in Kyoto. You know,
those Japanese very crafty and uh,
I will say a few things. Number one,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward
slash Tim you get to see all of these
spectacular underwear that I'd been
wearing and I am a bit of an underwear
connoisseur, socks, fashion sense with
sweat pants, not so much underwear.
I understand. So check them out and if
you go to mandy.com forward slash Tim,
he will also be able to see lots
of hot ladies wearing me undies,
female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for
both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
I love these underwear and a,
I'm going to be packing tonight probably
six to 12 pair to take with me to
Australia. They're great. Check them
out. [inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Tim this episode is brought to you by
audible, which I've used for years.
I love audiobooks and I've two
to recommend right off the bat.
Number one is pressed my
favorite audio book of all time.
And that is the graveyard
book by Neil Gaiman.
The only audiobook I've wanted to
immediately listen to a second time.
As soon as I finished. It's amazing.
You will thank me. The graveyard book.
The second is faggot
bonding by Rolf Potts,
which had a huge impact on my life and
formed the basis for a lot of what became
the four hour work week.
So all you need to do to get your free
audio book and a Free 30 Day trial is go
to audible.com forward slash Tim and
you can choose one of those two books,
the graveyard book vagabonding or
more than 180,000 audio programs.
So that could be a book. That could be
a magazine, that could be a newspaper,
could be a class. It's that easy.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim,
that's audible.com forward slash
Tim and grab a book. Enjoy.
If you want more of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can subscribe to the podcast on
iTunes or go to for our blog.com f o u r
h o U R B l o g.com where you'll
find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much, much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com
slash t Ferris.
That's t f e R R,
I s s or on Facebook at
facebook.com/tim Ferris.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.